bazi you're single i like that it's out
now
another vibe
so tell us about the inspiration behind
the song how did you how did you come up
with it
yeah i mean you know recently i've i've
just been trying to have
more fun making the music uh you know
less complication and you know
questioning stuff and just getting back
to the roots of why i started making
music in the first place
and uh you know i like that was a
testimony to that and i wanted to make
something
that had a different rhythm and that
moved differently from my other stuff
and to challenge myself to make
something new and
fresh and exciting for everyone coming
back into this new world
[Music]
you're into making songs about love
you're really good at that so talk to us
about how i like that
differs from the love songs we've
received from you in the past
yeah i mean i like that it's definitely
not about like a specific person or
anything it's just a feeling and an
energy and a positivity that i wanted to
bottle
and just put into a record well you
released about
five singles last year and due to the
pandemic they were deeply
deeply personal um are those going to be
potentially on the new album
coming up you know i i think maybe one
or two of them i'll put on the project
but um i think those were standalone
records as
not as much a part of like a bigger
cohesive thing that i'm working on
separately now
so i i think those were meant to do what
they did in the time but
uh the new music has an entire fresh
different
sound one good night is worth a thousand
words
[Music]
so how would you describe this new bazi
you talk about it
in a sense like before the pandemic
there was an era now post pandemic there
is an
era what is this new sound we're getting
definitely uh i mean it's just
closer to my true authentic voice you
know
it's not as influenced as by what other
people are making now and
and what music sounds like now it's
really me kind of getting to be isolated
in that time
and find the exact type of music i want
to make
so it's innovative it's fresh it's
different
the tempos are different the drums are
different the rhythms are different
you released a song called i don't think
i'm okay during the pandemic
talked about losing motivation lack of
[Music]
[Applause]
self-esteem
oh i don't think i'm okay
[Music]
okay um
[Applause]
[Music]
how was it for you just to to be that
authentic i mean you are an authentic
artist but just to get that off of your
chest
how was that for you yeah i mean you
know
being an artist it offers you know it's
the best job because it offers
an outlet to free the stuff that sits on
your soul and on your spirit
and you know in exchange for getting to
talk about in the music you get to you
know release it out of your system
so um you know i love doing that the
studio has always been like therapy for
me and anytime there's something i can't
verbalize with words you know music has
always helped me do that
i don't think i'm okay what's really
important yeah and you opened up on
twitter about
what a lot of people honestly struggled
with during the pandemic which is
going to you know habits alcohol drugs
to release the stress how are you doing
today are you are you do you feel like
you're in a better mind space
considering where we are in the world
yeah i'm
i'm in a better place um but you know
i think pain is something that we we
learn to deal with
and to go through our entire lives and i
don't think it's anything you could
ever you know fully say you're over but
i'm finding better outlets of ways to
release some of my
my you know stuff i have going on and
you know learning healthier habits to
take care of myself and to
you know put myself in a better position
to feel okay are you one of those
artists
you know sometimes you feel like artists
give you great music or are able to
write great music when they're going
through pain
do you do you associate yourself with
that type of artist
or can you make music when you're happy
and feeling good
you know it's definitely a mix of both
um but i'd say you know
definitely unfortunately some of my best
work comes at
some of my most unstable times in life
uh which is you know once again the
trade-off of the job but
you know to be in something and to get
to speak on it
ultimately is a gift because you know as
it may be
you know pain and trauma for you it's
also an outlet for somebody else or
millions of people to release that
sadness the same way that you got to
creating the songs
[Music]
well you are initially rose to fame
through vine
and musically
if you could look back to yourself when
you first started in this industry what
would you tell you
yeah i'd probably tell myself to just um
just to be yourself um to not worry so
much about
what other people might expect from you
or want to see from you but
to you know i feel like we all spend our
entire lives trying to find that true
personal opinion that's unaffected by
the outside world and
you know i'd say to just get closer to
that you know really find out what you
like
really find out the music you like
really find out the type of music you
really want to make and
um you know just continue trying to be
yourself
you were preaching bossy this is
inspirational
seriously that's a good point i love
that
okay well pre-fandemic you were touring
with justin timberlake camila cabello
and this year you were even nominated
for a grammy
well we know you are a justin timberlake
fan
is there any future where we can see a
collaboration with you too
uh maybe you never know i
i don't know it's a good question what
do you want to manifest
coming up if you don't mind sharing
because i'm if you want to keep your
dreams to yourself i believe in that as
well but what do you want to manifest i
mean it's you know honestly my goals
have really simplified
um you know from wanting the accolades
and stuff like that it's a lot less of
that and you know i just want my music
to reach people i wanted to touch people
and
i want to kind of let all the
opportunity unfold
in the present rather than you know
trying to think so far about how things
can happen and
the way things can go down you know my
goal now is to try and be
as present as possible and to allow the
good things to happen the way that they
should and naturally and you know not
trying to force anything and
uh yeah just put it back in the art less
about
you know the appreciation for it sorry
well new album
when can fans expect it any fun collabs
interesting collabs we can expect
yeah keeping a little dl about the album
right now but uh
it's a really really special project and
that's by far my best work to date
[Music]